alright we're taking calls at 6 1 7 830
4750 the phone lines are jammed packed
currently 17 people are holding but the
lucky next caller is from the 864 area
code caller where are you calling from
and what's your name uh Greer South
Carolina awesome and what's on your mind
I'm actually wondering I've been I've
watched you and secular talk for a long
time now and I know that Bernie Sanders
has a lot of the issues that are on his
side I'm wondering why doesn't he move
to do like more referendums like I see
we did they'd add the brexit referendum
and we have all these referendums why
isn't he moving for like a single pair
referendum you're saying like a national
referendum that would be equivalent to
what happened with brexit in the UK but
but but for single-payer hell yeah yeah
but you're saying that same thing where
the entire country would basically vote
do we want single-payer yeah I mean I
think the reason I mean Honoria it's
something I would see but I think the
reason you don't see Bernie Sanders
putting too much energy into that is
Bernie Sanders can just not make that
happen I mean that would be it can't
just depend on Bernie Pat and while die
I think that that would be fascinating
you have to imagine what you would have
to go through to have a national
referendum on something like that I
don't even know how many different
layers could veto it but it would just
not happen yeah because the national
referendum would be an example of a
direct democracy which we don't really
have in this country that's not laid out
in the Constitution sure states can vote
on different issues but not the country
at large yeah I mean Bernie would the
easiest path forward for Bernie to
catalyze that would be to basically
campaign for all 50 states to decide to
have that referendum and also just
because you have the referendum doesn't
mean that then you are going to actually
have the federal government put in place
and fund such a program so i think that
quite frankly although I agree I want
national health care Bernie Sanders
doing that would be a waste of time you
need a constitutional amendment to get
that referendum in place which could
arguably be harder than just getting
single-payer to begin with real
legislature yeah yeah does that make
some sense
well I know a few the states have kind
of moved to do it on a statewide basis I
figured which one is also top my head
Vermont had a plan to do it and it sort
of fell apart oh yeah yeah well it's
that great idea great to hear from South
Carolina really really appreciate the
call